en principio saúl me gustaría saber
justamente por qué esa diferencia de
título en inglés y en español la selva
negra y la selva moderna pues es una
forma de metáfora para hablar de los
cambios que hay dentro de las
comunidades como lo que viene de fuera
que está moldeando
lo que hay dentro de las comunidades
es por eso y bueno la selva negra es
porque el lugar el lugar se llama
también en la región donde donde viven
los personajes se llama selva negra es
conocido así de manera local
pero esto nos hace pensar pues eso eso
también esa metáfora de la selva negra
en donde viven don juan y doña carmen
justamente don juan y doña carmen son
dos personajes muy digamos entre
comillas coloridos es gente que tiene
algo que contar es alguien que son
personas a las que ustedes fueron que
fueron a buscar para que les para que
contarán al público su historia cada uno
en sus particularidades tienen algo que
contar sobre esa selva sobre sus cambios
que se están viviendo como no podemos en
este momento verlos para que la gente se
haga una idea de qué manera la
modernidad y de qué manera la
globalización está afectando las vidas
de esas dos personas de donjuán que es
un chamán y de doña carmen como como lo
están viviendo ellos los donjuanes este
es una persona que se dedica a la
medicina tradicional es un curandero
por una situación de desigualdad
habiendo estado de chiapas en méxico la
pobreza él tiene que tiene que hacer
trabajos forzados digamos o trabajos
pesados desde vender leña pero tiene que
cargar leña no es temas que son propios
pesos entonces esto le genera una
enfermedad
una ruptura y entonces espero esa hernia
él no lo puede curar con su medicina él
tiene que recurrir a médicos que tienen
esa preparación para poder hacerlo pero
desafortunadamente el sistema de salud
en chiapas es deficiente de manera
general no hay medicamentos
pues tampoco le prestan bien los
servicios tiene que ir
en distintos momentos para que le hagan
su revisión y si nosotros nos ponemos en
la situación de don juan don juan no
tiene los recursos para estar viajando
como como es en la práctica de los
médicos no que hay una cita cada cierto
tiempo y él no tiene los recursos para
para hacer eso pero a pesar de todo él
hace el esfuerzo para ir a estos
a los centros de salud desde el gobierno
y este pues le detectan que tiene la
hernia y que la hernia pues ha sido
producido por por estos trabajos pesados
ajá
en el caso de doña carmen de qué manera
entonces en es en su caso la modernidad
y la globalización tiene un efecto
directo sobre su vida en esta comunidad
particular en el caso de doña carmen la
vida de ella es este particular porque
él
el esposo fue una de las personas que
éste
lucho por las tierras antes antes este
de
años atrás en las tierras todas las
tierras ejidales que habían se los
fueron quitando se fueron quitando una
sola persona hasta que llegó el punto en
que se quedaron sin nada sin nada ya no
tenían nada de tierras para cultivar y
pues éste la gente se preocupaba porque
no tenían para comer entonces éste el
esposo doña carmen emprendió una lucha
para recuperar esas tierras y poderlas
trabajar y lo que hizo fue denunciar
ante él ante la autoridad del estado
esta injusticia que estaban viviendo
ellos y como consecuencia que mandan a
matarlo el mismo día de la denuncia
entonces
ella se queda prácticamente sola y tiene
que vivir como puede y con las
consecuencias de esto también del
movimiento que su marido había
emprendido claro y que en realidad
resultó resultó mal para ella finalmente
signar claro se se quedó sola para
siempre no creando sola a sus hijos ella
menciona también que había un bebé
también que murió de tristeza y tristeza
porque había dejado las no habían dejado
solo entonces éste
y de alguna manera la comunidad regresa
como una forma de agradecimiento regresa
un poco de tierra a doña carmen y doña
carmen
prácticamente desarrolla su vida en este
espacio hay corta leña hace su vida
diaria fritura maíz frijol calabaza
aguacate durazno
y ahí viven es autosuficiente es
autosuficiente pero si con esa soledad
siempre
en esta línea
apple